so you know it's easy sometimes to fall
into the trap of thinking that there's
no clear right or wrong side in our
present culture war everyone is equal
parts
right and wrong or everyone's just wrong
flat out you know you might think and
you hear this a lot from from people
it's kind of nihilistic way of thinking
about it
uh nihilism disguised as as nuance well
i think everybody is
everyone is equally wrong in all ways
what may lead you to this conclusion
is the simple fact that all of the
individual people on
every side of every issue are flawed
often deeply flawed
prone to hypocrisy self-contradiction
stupidity
and there's so much of all that stuff to
go around hypocrisy self-contradiction
stupidity
that um you may be tempted to sort of
throw up your hands and say well forget
it doesn't matter
there's no difference between the two
sides the fight is over nothing
i don't care anymore it's easy to make
this mistake
but it's still a mistake and it's
helpful to remind yourself
sometimes that there is a bad side and a
good side here
it's not simplistic to put it that way
which brings us to
jennifer gunter she's a prominent
abortion proponent
and abortionist um so following the the
saga here
following the discussion gunter on
saturday um
over twitter first challenged gop house
minority leader kevin mccarthy to a
quote public factual discussion on
abortion
now another user not mccarthy someone
else on twitter responded
with more respect and civility than this
person deserves in my opinion
and that that twitter user said as long
as the discussion begins with accepting
that an implanted embryo is a living
human organism
as a doctor you can confirm this
mccarthy's background is in business so
try
senator sass or marco rubio who have
background in law and can explain that a
living human organism is a person
now gunter shot back to this random
twitter user
and said an embryo isn't a human
it's a human embryo and don't effing
tell me what i know as a doctor
now stop there for a second an
embryo isn't a human it's a human embryo
well that makes no sense
that of course is like me saying that
middle-aged women like gunter
aren't human they're human middle-aged
women
it makes no sense at all if you're a
middle-aged woman
you are in a phase of human development
if you're a middle-aged man
same if you're an elderly person if
you're a teenager
it's a it's a stage a phase of human
development if you're a quote fetus
you're also in a stage of human
development
and the thing about being in a stage of
human development is that you must be
first a human in order to be in that
stage
there has never been a tree or a cow or
an earthworm
that is a human embryo or a middle-aged
woman because you need first to be human
to be any of those other things
anyway gunter continued on twitter this
time responding to someone who addressed
her by just her last name
god forbid and she said it's dr
gunter to you we're discussing the
subject of my expertise
then she says the unborn are zombies
that doesn't apply here use medical
terms or at least grown up words an
embryo is a human embryo
it's not a human medical
words medical terms zombie apparently is
a medical term
and children at their youngest ages are
zombies
this comment if it reminds you of
anything it's a bit reminiscent of
another abortionist
leah torres who a little while ago i
think a couple years ago
uh responded to someone asking her if
the sound of her victims keeps her up at
night
and she responded to that by saying you
know the fetus can't scream right i
transect the cord
first so there's really no opportunity
if they're even far enough along to have
a larynx
now this is what you get from one side
and
these are not extreme
or outlier cases yeah i'm not pulling
the most extreme
pro-abortion rhetoric and say well this
is representative of the entire
side no this this what's being expressed
here is the the necessary result
of the dehumanizing of children in their
earliest stages of development
if it sounds nasty and cruel and awful
it's because
dehumanization is a nasty cruel awful
business
in our culture it's cloaked in euphemism
and described in sanitary clinical terms
but the reality is that a group of
people are being excluded from the human
category
and throughout human history there have
always been people
doing this you know people trying to
exclude other people
from the people club there have always
been people throughout history who point
over there and say
those people aren't people
we still have not graduated beyond that
this mentality is just migrated to
different areas and different sorts of
people
but still it exists and the attempt to
do this to dehumanize to
de-person entire groups of of of persons
is always evil and the results are
always horrifying and always bloody
and the people doing it are always on
the wrong side
this all becomes more obvious when
people like quote unquote dr
gunter here make the mistake of being
more momentarily honest
unborn babies aren't zombies obviously
but she's honest
in that she's revealing what she has to
tell herself in order to justify what
she believes and what she has done
this is what she has to whisper to
herself at night in order to sleep
and i think it's helpfully clarifying
for the rest of us to hear
people like gunter say this out loud
and that's why i return to this issue
abortion as often as i do first of all
because
it's the greatest moral crisis of our
time millions of innocent people are
being slaughtered
i think it's a pretty good reason to
discuss the issue frequently i would
think
also though because because because of
that clarification that it that it
offers
that this this this cuts through the fog
it parts the clouds
and it makes it clear where you stand
if you stand on the side where unborn
babies are zombies
who can be put down and discarded you're
the bad guy
you are the bad guy in this whole
drama there is no moral equivalence
whatever criticisms you can make of the
people on the other side of that divide
and there are plenty of valid criticisms
the fact remains
that they want babies to live and
you want them treated as sub-human trash
it's funny to me when pro-abortion
people use pro-birth
as a pejorative you hear this all the
time
that's another clarifying thing they
accuse pro-lifers of being merely
pro-birth
i always hear this oh you're just
pro-birth
well am i supposed to recoil at that
label
because i don't pro-birth well sure yeah
i'm pro-birth
i will i will happily admit that i am
pro-birth
i am in favor of babies being born
once the baby is conceived yes i i want
him to be born
that's every every baby that is right
now in the womb of
a mother i want all those babies to be
born i am pro-birth
you if you're on the other side you are
pro-dismemberment
i i feel comfortable with where i am
and though i can't defend everything
that everyone on my side says or
believes
and i could personally do without some
of the kooky conspiracy stuff that folks
on the right seem attracted to
more than i wish they were the fact is
that we are fighting
to protect the most vulnerable and the
other side
wants to kill the most vulnerable this
is
literally life versus death right verse
wrong
good verse bad there is no gray area
at least where it matters most listen
hit that subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated